good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday getting down in front of
the day
hey Jax happy Friday happy Friday Claude
I know you're looking forward to the
weekend even though your weekend is kind
of already kicked off yeah it's off it's
off without a hitch you're in the midst
of your weekend I'm Misty how's your
weekend going
would you like something to butter your
weekend
good one
good one would you like us to assign
someone is out of your muffin
um weekend is going off great I'm in the
Hamptons podcasting live from the
Hamptons I uh hit up a spritz event
yesterday at Surf Lodge which was just
an absolute blast great way to kick off
the weekend
um it's raining which is so disgusting
and really kind of offensive to my
people
um but other than that I'm having a
great weekend how's your I know it feels
like we're podcasting on a Saturday
because yesterday felt like a Friday but
it's Friday today yes it's Friday today
officially Friday happy for everyone the
weather is gloomy which I kind of am
feeling like I was sleeping and it was
rain was driving thunder lightning and I
was like this is just truly gorgeous for
me but not for someone who trekked out
to The Hamptons for the weekend and who
was hoping to perhaps catch a tan right
not great news so I'm sorry your loss is
my gain but and I do have the stride
brother in here the rain held off for
their walk this morning so they were
they were feeling hashtag grateful and
now they're just pooped okay well while
the rain is obviously not what I wanted
to hear this morning I heard something
else this morning that is exactly what I
wanted to hear oh and what is that
somebody made an amazing Point who I
believe it was someone in our Facebook
group
um because you know yesterday you and I
were really kind of struggling you know
trying to figure out a way to make the
uh writer strike about us right and I do
believe I have successfully found a way
to make it about us ready okay
so there's a Litany of things that
people in Sag are not allowed to do
while the strike is ongoing you know of
course working on any projects touring
promoting projects
so that means that nobody can go on
Smart lists
while the writers strike is going on and
that means no you know big stars going
on the podcast and you know
automatically shooting that podcast
episode up to number one on the charts
you know we're we're kind of
consistently number two these days and I
think our hopes of perhaps eclipsing I
don't know all the smartless guys are in
Sag like do you think they'll stop the
podcast as a part of the strike I don't
know that's what I would that was my
next question okay so this is a lot to
process obviously I understand it's a
little bit exciting but I also think
like they're so far ahead in how many
episodes they bank that like we won't
feel the effects for a while
like it's true but is them releasing
episodes with other people promoting
things a violation of the strike I don't
think so because then Barbie can't come
out next week
right yeah no that's true I mean again
not to make everything about us but this
writer strike is impacting me in other
ways as well you know I think I said
this maybe on the patreon or on the
regular toast episodes this week I can't
remember but I um had the privilege of
being invited to the Oppenheimer
Premiere because Josh Peck one of our
good guys podcast host is in Oppenheimer
um and I got the call yesterday you know
the premiere was off
oh no in tandem with the strikes so like
you know I finally got invited to
something cool and I can't even go
that's messed up
I know
we do have more strike news today so we
will get into it I am gonna start to
think about like how this smartless
stuff could affect us and if they should
even be putting out episodes like while
their comrades are on strike I just feel
like it's kind of it's in bad taste yeah
yeah it's giving out of touch
but I do I don't I'm pretty sure
podcasting is not a part of like sag
even though the the three of them are
sag members you know what I mean right
right and also like it's unscripted so
that's not like part of the writers but
as we've noticed like a lot of people
are foregoing things that have nothing
to do with sag just to stand with sag
like how the MTV Awards were canceled
and Lala Ken said she wouldn't go even
though she's not in you know I don't
believe she she actually might be in Sag
but not from Vanderpump rule no like she
people were like not going to those
award shows to stand with the writers
right so like maybe you shouldn't put
out your podcast to stand with the
writers yeah I actually think it would
be a very bad look if the smartless guys
continue to put out episodes while the
strike is ongoing I really I think it
would be in very poor taste I agree
they're the only ones in comedy though
who I feel that way about because
they're like such beacons in the film
and TV industry but they actually are
like we're not even joking like yeah
everyone else is just like a slob like
us you know like right and we slobs we
slobs have no you know backbone we have
no principles we're not married to
anyone we're not unioned we don't need
to stand for anything and we don't
and we don't and we but the smartless
guys you know and we won't and the
smartless guys you know they're so
principled well you know what now is the
time to see if you really are so if they
continue to put out episodes I just
think that'll be disgusting yeah and I I
think they might have to be canceled
#smartless is over party
I think it's a it's really kind of the
only choice we have to support just to
support the writers you know we have to
cancel smartless it's so clear what our
choice to be done a hundred percent
so
do it that way you will
do without what you will and think you
know the next time you want to go listen
to a fabulous episode of smartless say
is this what the writers would want no
am I are my choices affecting the
writers
it's true but you can rest easy knowing
like Claudia and I have nothing to do
with the industry with sag with anything
in any real official capacity like if
it's legit they don't know us
yeah like we if you need just kind of to
be like a little bit more clear we are
we are seriously irrelevant uglies we
are nomads we are tied to nothing and
nobody like we are untethered we are
rootless like we stand for nothing so it
is okay this episode is safe like you
can listen it's so true like I can't
stress that enough you know yeah
and I just I have a feeling Jackie like
dead serious like we might hit number
one like I'm being for real
if they're ever we always say like if
smart list goes on vacation no if there
ever was a time it would be now you
think it's today no I'm telling you it
will be like in a few weeks no no sorry
I'm not saying today I'm saying like
during this strike Like This is Our
Moment oh my God I'm looking at the
charts right now and the smartless
episode that is number four not number
one because Tom Holland was on but
number four and it's very clear why it's
not number one is um the live from
Boston MIT professor
oh
oh the way I'm like obsessed with
smartless and I have literally never
listened to an episode yeah no but you
watch their show so yeah you know stuff
I know something and because they put
some of the live episodes in their
docusary so right you're familiar now
I'm familiar well all's that to say make
sure to listen to the toast and if
you're listening on Spotify that's so
great we think thank you so much for the
support but like maybe head over to
Apple you know leave a review yeah maybe
just like for this one episode stop what
you're doing switch over to Apple and we
just can like conglomerate yeah we can
combine our forces
yeah kind of like the writers
there's power in numbers
I'm glad I got that off my chest
me as well I look forward to seeing if
this Bears any fruit
um and if your theory is correct yeah I
want yeah I'm looking forward to seeing
like what the smartless guys they're
probably panicking like oh my God the
toast is coming for our neck what do we
do we can't let them be number one
that's probably like they're having a
meeting on Zoom right now for sure hey
guy hey boys hey boys
uh collab soon
collab that's a lot of people on One
podcast I think we'd have to go
separately
I wouldn't want to do it without you
it's so true I don't want to do anything
without you it's so true yet you're in
the Hamptons gallivanting without me
how's my boy Jackie's watching Theo for
the weekend I must have called four
times last night like I'm obsessed how
would say he's so great you called me
when I was already like in the bedroom I
figured where it's like turned in for
the night I turned in it's lights out uh
but he is doing great him and Harry are
having such a blast Bruno is having his
internal struggle but he does get his
moments like of of Joy being mommy sweet
angel and I and that buoys him to get to
the next day but overall it's been
really lovely
I'm so glad and you know
you and I did chat last night but I
think everyone should know like I was in
I was in the Uber with Brian he was
asking me so many questions about the
camper the counselor you know like Dad
energy he just had questions and I was
like trying to recite what I know of the
book from memory but to be honest I need
to memorize the whole thing it's like I
couldn't I couldn't hack it and so I
just decided to what if I just call
Jackie up and get a live reading from
the author herself and we all were in
the car we like put the phone up and
Jackie read the book for us you guys
literally everyone was crying in the
back of this Uber
um and it felt like it was a great
moment for mothers for fathers for
campers for counselors and I think
everybody should head over to the camper
in the counselor.com to get a copy or
head over to talk shop live to get a
signed copy are they still available
they are still available all of the
links to all of the different retailers
are in my bio or you could go to
campgroundcounselor.com you could get it
straight up on Amazon you know if that's
straight up if that's how you like to do
it um you could go to Indie bound Trulia
if you want to support small bookshops
like there's a million ways to skin this
cat and get this book so thank you to
everyone who's already pre-ordered and
if you've been on the fence like pull
the trigger
to it like Nike
what if you just pre-ordered the book
the winding Camp roads give me
goosebumps and chills gorgeous that was
me driving to the Hamptons yesterday I'm
like Ben are these winding Camp roads
giving you Goosebumps and chills
oh another major life update have you
ever had Blaze Pizza
uh yes I have because I did like an ad
for them literally six years ago
okay like I obviously know what it is
it's one of a it's like a newer fast
food you know place it's not like it's
not an obvious one you know it's not
like McDonald's or Burger King but me
and Ben were driving the Hamptons and oh
my God I was so hungry I thought
I was gonna faint and like I just needed
to you know when you need to eat like
eat the first thing that you see in your
line of vision yeah that was me and I
just I saw a Blaze Pizza and I was like
What if I just got Blaze Pizza I never
had it before
um well all I know about it is that they
serve pizza and I think it's partially
owned by LeBron James so I was like okay
a convergence of my two things pizza and
celebrities and my expectations were low
I'm not gonna lie when I tell you it was
so delicious like it's basically
like Chipotle for pizza like you could
just make your own pizza and it's like
really thin crust it was so good like me
and Ben were obsessed and they had found
soda oh and I walked in and guess what
song was playing I knew I was gonna have
a positive experience when I heard the
song I think you put on your story
I said it was country so there's the
genre Luke Combs
no it's a kind of a deep cut it's not an
obvious country but for us we love her
and it
who it's a song we're always singing
I don't know
uh promise I didn't know he was young
man by Kim like so Random I was like oh
this place is lit and then me and the
guy who are making the pizza like we
kind of have this unique connection
um he thought I was hilarious and
therefore you know
I adored him because the you know the
number one way to my heart is just to
tell me I'm funny oh my God he was
cackling and I didn't even say anything
that funny I was just like oh man I
can't find my husband Ben was like
walking around the block looking for
something else I'm like we're just gonna
eat place pizza and then you never found
your husband again now you have a new
husband now I slept with the Blaze Pizza
guy he's here with me this weekend
is he gonna be our Sports correspondent
on the podcast today
uh no he's not really into sports oh
what's he into
Pizza
that's awesome yeah it was I just wanted
to say like I'm I kind of pride myself
on being you know really well versed in
the fast food universe and I had like
never had it and now that I have like I
will be having it again it was excellent
okay great are you gonna go to that one
on your way home so you can see your man
it was honestly
yes it was honestly gorgeous it was so
clean I used the bathroom too and it was
like so divinely clean
um except I will say I got a chocolate
chip cookie and it was one of the most
disgusting things I've ever had in my
life like I actually couldn't even
finish it which is so not like me
because even a bad chocolate chip cookie
is like still a cookie yeah it's still
like cookie flour sugar I mean chocolate
flour sugar cookie flour sugar so it was
disgusting and they need to work on that
but they sold beer and wine and I'm like
how do we need to get Spritz and Blaze
we do also like maybe you should have
done the partnership with blaze six
years ago no literally I'm obsessed or
today not you Jackie not you just kind
of like sitting on this secret of Blaze
like you knew and you didn't tell me
yeah no and I remember there's not a
blaze in the city so I had to go outside
I think I went uh to towards New Jersey
for it I went to Queens
at least takes you to amazing places
you really do and like there were all
these like teenagers it's clearly like a
local spot where like everybody just
like chills and like
it's like a nice after school hangout
because it was like Thursday maybe three
o'clock like the kid just got out of
school they're like eating pizza like
playing on their phones like it just
honestly was kind of idyllic
wow beautiful day
it really was it took us forever to get
to The Hamptons yesterday literally if
you do the drive to The Hamptons it's
one Highway literally it's the Long
Island Expressway the entire way it's
the most boring drive because you just
don't do anything and when we get in the
car Ben's like I have a Google Maps Ben
doesn't use apple so I have Google Maps
also he's like let's use Waze I'm like
why Google Map like I'm like what's the
big deal he's like I like to see Waze
tells you when there are cops I'm like
oh okay
insane driver I'm gonna call the
cops on him he's dodging the popo you
know I'm going to say get his gear rise
his new license plate number yeah and
I'm gonna call whenever I'll track you
yeah because I have your GPS and then
I'll call the local sheriff and say
there's a Madman on the LIE
so we used Waze and when I tell you we
were not on the Long Island Expressway
for one minute I didn't even know there
was a way to get to The Hamptons that
doesn't just take the LIE all the way to
Manorville like I we were and the time
kept going up like literally we were
supposed to get there I think 355 we got
here at five o'clock it was the longest
drive ever by the time we got out of the
car like we were so done with
each other we were like literally hating
hating each other's guts and I think
that's kind of why the Blaze Pizza Guy
was so like easily able to come between
us because we were vulnerable you were
vulnerable and so you're saying Waze
took you on a bad path yeah it wasn't
the ways to go and that's what Waze does
now like people are still like living in
this fantasy that weighs like they'll
circumvent the traffic and you'll find
in the streets that nobody knows about
like ways to ruined you guys don't no
like you will you will circumvent the
traffic and you will find New Roads but
like at what cost no and everyone else
who's using wages on those roads yes
it's so true there was like all these
other forlorn cars clearly going to The
Hamptons on these like random ass back
roads we were all just looking at each
other what have we done right to those
of us who are a step ahead are going
back to the major highways where
everyone has left because they're
following ways yeah
so that was like a little bit about my
day
thus far okay well thank you for sharing
you're welcome thank you for opening up
it's been a pleasure and how was your
party
oh the sports party was fabulous you
know I hadn't been to Surf Lodge on a
Thursday night ever if you go on surf
Lodge like you know for those who don't
know like the one of the most popular
places to go out in Montauk and it's a
mad house on the weekends like it's so
fun but it's so packed and I guess like
on the weekdays they do different types
of events that are much more chill and
oh my God it was Heavenly like because
if you've been to Surf Lodge it's so
beautiful it's on the water and it's a
sunset but it's hard to focus on the
beauty of it all on the weekends because
it's just so packed so much energy so
many people it was so civilized there
was like a live band we had drinks we
had dinner it was amazing I literally I
so underrated to go on a Thursday night
it was so beautiful we had a great time
then we just came back and swam I went
to bed early watched a little young
Sheldon it was it was gorgeous gorgeous
yeah really good stuff well we'll set
you a sale on your weekend first we have
to deliver the fast five stories plus a
little TV recap I watch Kardashians I
don't think you did I did not but the
fifth and final story is coupled with
the TV recap so without further ado you
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know is brought to you by eBay
authenticity guarantee Jackie and I love
to invest whether it's in purses
clothing shoes we are always making sure
to shop smart with eBay authenticity
guarantee eBay authenticators are there
verifying every detail of your purchase
eBay authenticity guarantee protects
buyers from fakes and gives them the
assurance that they're getting the real
deal because what is worse than spending
time and money scouring the internet for
your next purchase only to later find
out that you've been scammed with eBay
authenticity guarantee you will never
get faked over again the service
currently covers eligible items across
sneakers watches handbags jewelry and
streetwear Jackie and I feel more
confident in ordering online knowing
that an expert at eBay is authenticating
our items any purchase backed by
authenticity guarantee is sent to the
authentication team who personally
inspects they inspect the item they
check it against the listing and
authenticate it in a world full of fakes
it's time to get real with eBay
authenticity guarantee so ensure your
next purchase is the real deal with eBay
authenticity guarantee everyone deserves
real visit ebay.com for terms that's
ebay.com for terms make sure to check
that out because it's investing season
we all want to look our best summer
sales summer things you know we've all
got weddings to attend and we want to
invest in good things we want to make
sure that they're you know the real deal
so ebay.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by impossible Foods it is hot Grill
summer you know we gotta cook meat we're
all outside this summer not today
because it's raining but impossible
Foods once you and your grill to join
them in making meat history so as you
may or may not know impossible beef is
Yum Yum Yum Yum Yum delucioso it tastes
like beef and historically speaking you
know beef is delicious but it's made
from plants and impossible has zero
animal hormones and 19 grams of protein
per serving plus it's better for the
planet and where would the planet be
without meat made from plants
so if you're looking for options on what
to grill this summer grab impossible we
uh we eat a lot of impossible Jackie
specifically because she uh
likes you know plant-based meat and we
keep kosher
um I just had an impossible beef burrito
on a Delta flight that was so
unbelievably delicious which was a real
treat for me because I can never eat
meat on planes because it's not Kosher
um so impossible is just kind of out
here changing the game for everyone and
everything their beef patties are so
good it's so good for the planet it's
good for you it has 19 grams of protein
it's just a fabulous alternative so this
summer when you're thinking about
grilling you know think about your
vegetarian friends think about your
friends who are trying to you know
minimize their meat conception think
about your kosher friends and head over
to the impossible food section at your
local grocer and you know think of
others okay
so let's make meat history today head
over to the meat aisle at your local
store grab some impossible beef or
patties and get grilling because it's
hot girl summer and some of us are
hungry so think of impossible foods for
sponsoring today's episode thank you
our first story I will say these stories
are in no particular order okay
Joe Jonas reveals an embarrassing moment
in his life when he pooped himself on
stage
yep so while appearing on Kiss FM's will
and Woody Radio Show in Australia on
Thursday the singer was asked to tell a
story he's never told before in reply he
spilled the beans about the time he
pooped his pants on stage he said I was
with a few friends yesterday we were
just talking about how there's a point
in your life where as an adult you can
remember the last time you shot your
pants he said that the incident happened
four years ago and that he was saved by
a rapid costume change he said it's
fresh but I've been able to work through
it a lot of therapy he said let's just
say it was a bad day to choose to wear
white clothing you might you think it
might be a little too it might have been
a little something else a little
something extra okay ill so it was like
mid wardrobe change during the set
if you go in the archives there's a
wardrobe change halfway through the show
and it was maybe a little bit like oh
that was an interesting choice to change
clothes out quickly that's a story I've
never told before he said it was a light
one it wasn't a full so I was able to
tell the tale okay let me know if you
want more details on the colors no smell
oh my God
no he literally is being so detailed
it's borderline offensive
um I do often wonder about people who
perform so much like I've never seen you
know like a star sneeze like how does
Taylor Swift like not have to sneeze for
the whole three hours you know what I
mean I mean your body does like kind of
get with the program when you have like
a lot riding on things like
your body just like figures it out but I
think when you perform so much like
you're obviously
bound to something to go wrong and I do
often think about that so I'm glad he
told the story because I I did wonder
but he did you know go into such grave
detail I'm
as somebody who like at one point was
really attracted to Joe Jonas I'm
definitely second guessing myself yeah I
think it's really generous of you to
compare like your pants to a
sneeze which like a sneeze is so
involuntary no for sure but I'm like
more so I'm really talking about like
just bodily functions that we experience
every day that you really can't
experience on stage yes I agree with
that like even having to pee
right they schedule time for people I
said I'm sure like you plan your
drinking beforehand
um it just sounds like he was getting a
little Brazen with his farts on stage
yeah I mean that probably starts a lot
on stage and he just like kind of got
confused
I mean it's kind of the perfect place to
fart it's so loud nobody's gonna hear
you
um Everybody in the room is like jumping
sweating screaming crying throwing up
like there's just smells everywhere like
No One's Gonna assume that the smell is
like something you created right so I I
get that I do that's why you know
I think we'd all be lying if we said
like you know none of us have ever like
farted at a club it's really the perfect
place to fart
um having said that
um it was a lot of detail
yeah it was but it's a slow news day so
this is big no he could he couldn't have
chosen a worse time to tell the story
because it's getting way more pickup
than it normally what I've seen it
everywhere because there's really
nothing going on like everyone's on
strike so no one's like doing anything
it's like he told it in Australia like I
think he's and it made its way in this
corner of the world my American films
will never know they'll never find out
that's so funny and so true and I'm like
the timing truly couldn't have been
worse yeah now it's it's literally the
biggest story of the day I saw it like
three times this morning before we even
started recording it's the number one
Festival
it literally is the number one Fast Five
I'm so sorry Joe
um but your timing really could have
been better yeah
are you ready for our next story
Jake Owen is addressing the rumors that
claimed Taylor Swift Jacob Owen Jake
Owen the country the country star yeah
well deep cut he's so random but the
rumor is that Sparks Fly is about him
what and he's addressing the rumor
so
he said that he's not the man behind
Taylor Swift's okay Sparks Fly following
the release of speak now Taylor's
version the singer admitted he's aware
that swifties have theories about him
being the inspiration for the 2010 song
he said it's a great song and the
speculation has always been funny to me
I'm sure Taylor probably laughs at it
too but I'm happy to even have my name
in the discussion around it she's so
sweet she's an amazing girl and an
amazing artist it's been incredible to
see how she's grown as a musician and
what a global phenomenon she's become so
according to the swifties they speculate
that it's about him because she wrote
um Portland Oregon in the song's liner
notes allegedly hinting at their
performance in the city together like I
think she was opening for him 17 years
ago they performed in Portland and like
there's something about the song that's
Portland right Portland Oregon you know
I knew it like I didn't have enough time
to think
oh God
I like how do you say it Portland Oregon
but like
I know probably Oregon is how oregonians
say it but the way that I speak is like
through accentuated vowels I have to be
treated myself Oregon
probably like the best fun fact I
currently have in my Arsenal is that the
Oregon Trail was created by Kevin
O'Leary Mr Wonderful from Shark Tank
yeah and that was like a part of the
education company that he first sold
that made him like a billionaire and why
he's really eligible for being a shark
yeah as he should be
as he should be back it's taken me years
to like realize really when I used to
watch the show in Earnest you know
before you know it's just a young girl
before he became jaded yeah when I was
just young I thought he was like really
unnecessarily mean I agree and now I'm
like these people need to hear this he's
saving people time and money and by not
sugar coating their bad ideas
no you are a hundred percent right I
think it's kind of that thing where like
you watch TV for many years of your life
Sex in the City and your your POV on the
characters as a young person versus you
know once you're matured it changes
completely yeah like I would definitely
be the Simon now maybe growing up I
fencing myself a little Paul a Randy you
were definitely a random like people
need to hear hard truths and nobody
wants to say it nobody wants to be the
one
but you're gonna be the one I would be
the one now no I agree with you
completely I used to be like oh my God
are you so mean but like sometimes these
people like are so dumb and they need to
be told that and like some of the other
sharks just say like nonsense in order
to get out of the deal because they
obviously don't want to be a part of the
deal so they're like
yeah but like wonderful at least takes
the time to let them know why like he
doesn't want to feel and like why your
idea is
totally knowledge
wait can we go back to Jake Owen yeah um
I had literally no idea his name was
even a part of the Swift Universe he's
such a random like old school country
artist
um having said that that's such a nice
thing to say about Taylor like that he's
just happy to be a part of the
conversation and
he's a cutie so like I could totally see
Taylor having like opened for him and
had a crush on him he's like extremely
good looking
um
and Sparks Fly is such a nice song like
it's yeah it's completely complimentary
I want to look up the lyrics
like it's just a very flattering song If
it's potentially written about you
yeah who else who do you have any names
in the mix for who it was I never I
never thought who is Sparks Fly about
like I think of the whole speak now era
as like about different people does he
have green eyes
hit me with those green eyes baby as the
lights go down give me something that'll
haunt me when you're not around
to Sean Meyer
John and I don't think so because I
don't think Sparks lies about John Mayer
has brown eyes okay okay he's a brown
girl
my Brown Eyed Girl
get me with those green eyes baby as the
lights go down because they were like
doing the show tour yeah and the lights
went down because then lights go up give
me something that'll haunt me when
you're not around oh that might be a
reference to haunted
which is also on speak now so if we can
figure out who's haunted is about too we
could perhaps connect the two mm-hmm
you and I walk a fragile line because
they work together I have known it all
this time but I never thought I'd live
to see it break okay I don't know what
that's about
I'm getting quiet and it's all tunes and
I can't trust anything now and it's
coming over you like it's all a big
mistake okay I don't know I just want to
say the songs about Jake Owen
she said like my mind forgets to remind
me you're a bad idea I imagine like when
he was 10 years older than her and uh
yeah probably married they work just
because
um you're a bad idea you touched me once
and it's really something you find I'm
even better than you imagined I would be
he literally just said that in the
interview like she's an amazing artist I
think he was probably like so taken
by her beauty her Talent her youth she
was even better than he imagined she
would be
she's on her guard for the rest of the
world but with him she knows it's no
good she could wait patiently but she
really wishes he would drop everything
now meet her in the morning it's very
rainy in the Pacific Northwest it's so
true he's on the sidewalk take away the
pain because she seeks Spark's life
whenever he smiles and maybe maybe his
show had pyrotechnics
but he also like has a gorgeous smile I
think he has him in the ears he's
extremely handsome he's like how do you
go on tour with this man and not write a
song about him honestly and like not
fall in love with him when you're the
opener so he's like much more famous
than you I'm sure he was a you know a
real mentor to her and he's so handsome
and she's so young and impressionable I
I never thought for I never would have
guessed it's about him but like it
totally could be it's totally about him
but I also think he has no idea it's
about him
right because it's really a song about a
crush it's not about two people who ever
fell in love it's like about right
it's a fantasy yeah it's like Enchanted
kind of
yeah so he has no ideas about him she
thinks like he thinks that she and him
are laughing about this together
meanwhile she's laughing at him that he
has no clue
totally we're not laughing with you Jake
we're laughing at you but I'm glad that
that he said this because now we know it
is about him no now we know he's a part
of the speak now Universe I did not know
that yeah and that he's a good one
yeah he seems like a nice guy
yeah and he's so handsome
yeah and he's like random too it's not
obvious like dummy are so obvious you
know
yeah like that's everyone's Crush but
like Morgan should be crushing on Jake
Owen
agreed agreed are you ready for our next
story yeah it's actually a great story
because we get to talk about Shark Tank
some more because Shark Tank star
Barbara Corcoran is showing off her one
million dollar mobile home
so Shark Tank star Barbara Corcoran
shocked fans when she took viewers
inside her mobile home in a tick tock
video posted by Caleb Simpson the
Creator known to document a host of
celebrity homes she's seen giving a tour
of her humble West Coast pad in affluent
Pacific Palisades uh she calls it a
double wide she said here's my Taj Mahal
she added explaining that she paid 800k
for the home and invested 150k more for
renovations her kitchen is equipped with
the leftover tiles she had at her New
York City Penthouse which overlooked
Central Park
um she said that she prefers her mobile
home which boasts ocean views to her
luxury Manhattan pad she said as
beautiful as my New York City Penthouse
is over the park with all this space it
does not have an ocean and there's no
arguing with the ocean there's an alert
to looking at the ocean that you can't
beat in my opinion
so you know Barbara's a queen having
said that this could never be me yeah
this is like one of your least favorite
celebrity Trends yeah like glorifying
you know
being middle class you know like I just
oh I won a house by the ocean and I'm
Barbara Corcoran let me go buy the
biggest one in Malibu like I love her
for not being wasteful like I get it but
like why don't you leave like the small
houses for people who need them you know
yeah but it's it's not it's not very
small it has two three bedrooms I
watched the video I watch a video it
must be like 1500 square feet yeah but
it can go on the road
no no I don't think it's like a mobile
home like that well it says mobile
it's not a mobile home you know how like
um
like like kind of in like a trailer park
like not all the houses are trailers
they're like the guests you could pick
them up and move them but like they're
planted in the ground you know what I
mean got it yes yes yes I mean it has to
be it's so big yeah it's very pretty and
very well done like the inside looks
like you know chip and Joe were there
yeah she said it's a part-time home for
her she uses it a number of weeks a year
and would be thrilled if she wanted 12
weeks a year honestly so she doesn't
like actually live there she said no no
no I like to see people use where I live
and make it warmer and you know they
just leave a little puddle of happiness
I feel behind when they move out at the
end of the week oh yeah and so basically
what she had said I watched the video is
that she saw this house like went up
knocked on the dorms like I want to buy
this house and the lady was like get the
out of here it's not for sale
and Barbara was like listen I'm gonna
buy it I'm gonna give you a great price
and you can stay here whenever you want
so I think the woman who sold it to her
like spends a lot of time there because
Barbara said she only spends a couple
weeks a year there okay and that's
pretty cool yeah that's cool but like
why
I don't know
I don't know I feel like there was
Corcoran is quirky
that Barbara Corcoran yeah that's
something that you need to know yeah but
I feel like it comes through on the show
it comes around the show but in real
life she's just as if not more quirky
Ben just shot a video series with her he
was like she was not what I expected I'm
like no I know she's like kind of
quirky she came on the breath ones and
she was not what I expected and then a
lot of times she'll do other shows and
sometimes what she says like goes viral
she says crazy stuff like the stuff like
when she said her and Whoopi like they
that she could like fit two of herself
and whoopee's pants
yeah she like
she's nuts I'm in so much trouble for
that but see she's not trying to like
start drama she's just like an oddball
quirky Queen right totally
so this maybe is just like one of those
things we're gonna chalk up to like
Barbara Corcoran Barbara Corcoran 100
yeah
and it's just so funny because like if
you live in New York I don't know if
Court I'm sure Corcoran exists outside
of New York but it's like the premier
real estate it is like Sotheby's it's
like so high brow and just knowing it
was started by quirky Barbara Corcoran
is so funny yeah it is really funny and
that is true I kind of forgot that
Corcoran is her
yeah I mean she I believe she sold it a
while ago but it's her name like
Corcoran it's all over like it's so
Elite like the biggest houses in the
Hamptons and penthouses are all quarker
and like it's so elevated and high brow
and it's just like this nutty little
lady you know yeah it's hilarious it
really is
oh are you ready for our next story no
no are you no
well I am about to be because the next
story is brought to you by Mattress Firm
trouble do you have a sleeping routine
you know I don't but I should and did
you know that having a sleep routine is
only one aspect of having a good night's
sleep and Mattress Firm can help with
that the first step is finding the right
mattress for your needs you can take
their mattress match or quiz on your
phone and you'll be matched with a high
quality mattress at every price point so
they have brands from you know
Tempur-Pedic Stearns and Foster Serta
purple Beauty Rest sleepies and if
you're looking for a convenient mattress
in a box Mattress Firm can also help you
with that so they're a mattress matcher
tool helps identify common sleep
disruptors like snoring tossing and
turning pain and it can pair you with
the right mattress to help alleviate
those disruptors plus but there are 120
night trial you have 120 sleeps to make
sure that it's perfect and of course
Mattress Firm has more than just
mattresses they have accessories
including cooling sheets pillows that
can help regulate temperature on hot
summer nights like these the last thing
you want to have to worry about is
delivery and Mattress Firm offers free
and fast delivery the difference between
having a great night's sleep and a bad
one is everything and the right mattress
matters Mattress Firm will help you find
yours they helped me and Ben find ours
we went to the store uh I believe like
four years ago the mattress is still in
amazing shape our mattress is from
Tempur-Pedic we got it from Mattress
Firm
and right now Mattress Firm is having
their Black Friday sale it's big deals
on better sleep and they are here early
so you can shop in store or online at
mattressfirm.com they're really both
premium experiences so again it's Black
Friday now A Mattress Firm big deals on
better sleep are here early shop in
store or online at mattressfirm.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by kiwico kiwico believes that every kid
is naturally creative and curious and
that Hands-On experiences builds
creative confidence and problem solving
skills that can change the world so
kiwico deliveries delivers seriously fun
Hands-On projects that inspire a
lifelong love of learning so kiwico
projects spark creative confidence for
ongoing tinkering and experimentation
sure you can buy a robot but wouldn't it
be way more fun to build your own it's
designed by experts so the projects are
designed by a team of Educators makers
engineers and Rocket scientists who
brainstorm hundreds of ideas to create
the most exciting age-appropriate and
educational projects they are real
engineering science and art projects
with high quality materials if you have
a kid or if you watch kids you know it
takes a lot to keep them entertained and
of course you want it to be like you
know stimulating and cubico is kind of
just that you know for kids and for
parents yeah it really is so hard to
find things that are intellectually
stimulating for the kids that they're
actually going to enjoy and get
something from and kiwico is an amazing
company that makes it so easy
they have something for kids of all ages
from infants and uh preschoolers to
teens and Beyond and the day the Box
arrives will sure to be your kids
favorite day of the month so give them
the tools to learn new skills build new
experiences and make connections to the
broader World redefine learning with
play explore Hands-On projects that
build creative confidence with kiwico
and get 50 off your first month plus
free shipping on any crate line at
kiwico.com toast that's 50 off your
first month at
k-i-w-i-c-o.com slash toast kiwico.com
toast you know who would love kiwico
you young Sheldon oh my God by the way
when I started doing the read I
literally thought the same thing
okay our next story Little writer strike
news the Oppenheimer star-studded cast
went on strike they made an early exit
from the UK premiere of their movie as
acting unions bring the industry to a
halt so an emotional Emily Blunt and
Florence Pugh led the charge as the
star-studded cast walked out of the
film's UK premiere on Thursday as
thousands of actors went on the biggest
strike to hit Hollywood in 60 years
you know these studios are so dumb
because like they should just agree they
just need to like negotiate and get to a
good place with the Union because we're
about to like enter into this like
Renaissance of movies like we were just
talking about earlier in this week how
theaters have been struggling and movies
have been struggling getting people in
theaters and now it's like this Barbie
hype in the Oppenheimer hype and now all
these moments are being you know
sidetracked because of the the strike so
it would really just behoove them to
make it work yeah I mean I think they're
trying to make it work it's just the Gap
is so wide that's what Fran was saying
like I feel like they're both trying to
come to the table but they're they
really can't see each other I don't know
what's gonna have to give you know
friend held a press conference and I
think she was asked like you know how
could you be gallivanting you know in
Italy Dolce Gabbana Kim Kardashian when
they're such an important thing going on
and she's like that is work like we are
working I'm sure Kim Kardashian would
rather be at home with her three kids at
her house like we are working I was
literally you know in three different
time zones up all night working with
everyone like I still have to work and
honestly I just like loved the direct
nature of her response like she was like
you yeah no she was taking no
and also like I think people need to
reserve that kind of outrage for like
politicians who are not like where they
need to be and like instead off
gallivanting like like seriously leave
Fred alone like she can do her job
remotely and it's like right you know
actors and writers and it's like they'll
be okay I have the like the utmost faith
in friend like that's what I was saying
the other day like you know it's friend
versus Bob I you're like but I really
I'm putting my money on Brown I just
feel like if Fran and Bob got into the
room they could just the two of them you
know kind of put set out all the noise
aside I think you can't drag you there's
so much red tape I know but I feel like
if it was the two of them they both seem
like like logical level-headed business
people like if they could just get to
talking
wait I kind of but like I feel like
this is the sort of like a romance novel
literally but she's ahead of no they're
on equal Playing Fields now because
he's a romance novel like they're it's
it's enemies to lovers and they have to
Brit and they have to like be locked in
a room like we're not getting out of
this room we're sleeping in the same bed
until we figure out and then they
literally they leave the room with you
know the best deal for everyone and you
know a ring on her hand yeah they need
to simplify this
yeah what is the name of this romance
book movie called where Fran and Bob
like
it's like something about like the art
of the deal you know or not like the SAG
Saga
no that's too obvious like one of my
books it would be called like the
exchange you know
totally I literally just read it was
horrible
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or no like
strike through her heart
right it's the deal he never expected
and she never wanted like something like
that that's good
obsessed we figured it out writing the
book somebody get Colleen on it but we
also have the solution to the strike
no I kind of ship I don't know what both
of their marital like situations are but
they are perfect for each other yeah and
just get the two of them in the room
together and this thing will sort itself
out no one else because other people I
see like other people have like
interests you know people have like best
interests and like agendas in in halting
things and you know everyone has their
agenda you got to look out for them but
I feel like Fran and bobber you know
they're operating they have their agenda
obviously but like for their people it's
the one that we know you know it's not
like the the back channeling that we
don't ulterior motive
yeah love that okay so solved just an
idea like I just want to say like going
to a Premiere getting like all dressed
and taking all the pictures and like
them leaving I just feel like the
premiere is counter-intuitive you didn't
really like make a statement because you
like the the part that happens next like
we don't even get to see and it's like
what you I I imagine they don't want to
see their movie again like they kind of
like
like gain the system they get to like
look like they're like hi I'm helping
it's performative but it was like better
for them that they only had to show up
for 20 minutes but they still got their
Getty photo right they got like the pr
which is the whole point of a Premiere
right right
like you could have like canceled the
whole Premiere and
it's a good point made a statement yeah
so I just don't really feel like they
did anything but um no that's a fact
that's my take no that's major facts and
then they did like this whole walkout
while the cameras were up thus making it
more you know the big press for the film
The the whole thing is more oppressed
for the film like we wouldn't be talking
about their UK Premiere like it was so
self-serving
no it was kind of perfect
mission accomplished look like a hero
look like a hero promote your move your
movie yeah not actually have to
sacrifice anything right get home
earlier not have to see this long ass
movie again go to bed happy but you got
your picks to post to the gram where you
can pretend like you were helping right
the cycle of performative activism
continues to move the cycle is complete
yes
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yes because Khloe Kardashian is
denying that she was shading Blac Chyna
China with comments about dreams so in
this week's episode of the Kardashians
extreme sixth birthday party Chloe's
talking a little bit about her role as
oh my God that was six years ago the
black and black China that makes sense
that's when we were like doing the
breath yeah I know it's just so crazy it
actually
feels like yesterday and I was doing a
Blaze Pizza hat yeah literally
um so Chloe talks about like her role in
dream's life and her role like as Rob's
sister and you can tell that she's
trying to be so delicate about the
matter and political the only thing that
she really says is like I feel like I'm
a third parent sometimes she never like
you know a what could have felt like
more true and harsher would have been
like I feel like dreams mom but she
didn't say anything like that like she
said I don't have a relationship with
dreams mom because she sued us for
hundreds of millions of dollars
um but like dream has her mom and I just
feel like a third parent sometimes
because I'm so close to Rob and like
true and dream are so close so I'm just
like always with dream
Chloe's role in dream's life like came
up a few times on the show and you could
really tell she like was struggling with
how to word what she was saying while
not being disrespectful so I think then
people took that and ran with it like
that she's a co-parent to dream she's
usurping dreams mom so she took to
Instagram to say it saddens me to see
clickbait headlines that are taken out
of context or Twisted to be something
that they're not I love all of my nieces
and nephews more than I can express she
said that she's particularly close with
dream my brother and I are extremely
close I'm with dream all the time
because I'm with my brother all the time
I love her beyond measure she also said
that she's really close with true
um I wholehearted she said I
wholeheartedly believe that it takes a
village to raise a child life is full of
ups and downs and I am proud that we
have a family that can lean on one
another that's what family does she said
Rob is doing the best he can as a parent
and in life Angela is doing the best she
can as a parent and in life and I am
doing the best I can as a parent and in
life we are all trying to do our best in
life
our children are healthy and happy so
she's really like slamming these
exaggerations
which is I'm sure so frustrating for her
because she really wasn't trying to say
anything
no and I think we learned that Rob has I
think primary custody of dreams so Chloe
being with dream all the time actually
makes a lot of sense
because she's so close with Rob right
and he knows he's with his daughter
Instagram is not reality but its dream
is always with yeah the kids the kids
and she should be because like there's
literally three other girls that are her
age a dream Chicago story and true and
stormy are like all the same age and
they like the same things no you should
grow up with your cousins there's
literally nothing wrong with us yeah I'm
just really curious like if anything has
changed between China and the girls
since China God
I know I feel like they would have that
in common and I was what I was about to
say is like I feel so um kind of
conflicted with the China thing because
like she was really horrible to the
Kardashians and I feel like the
Kardashians like did all that they could
for her and she ended up suing them for
hundreds of millions of dollars but I'm
also in this you know I'm following her
journey where like you know she's
getting her filler removed and she's
kind of like living this more modest
lifestyle and I'm really really like
rooting for her
um I think it's like a genuine change
so I don't know how to Grapple both
those ideas
yeah me too I mean maybe it just takes
time like maybe I think they are very
forgiving and a lot of things like
happen in their family they kind of have
to have like a short memory but I
imagine that like sure China says she's
changed and is changing but like you
kind of need to stick with it longer
before you're gonna like believe you
um but who knows if China even forgives
them because she feels like she was
wronged by them right but it would be
better for everyone if everyone could
get on the same page so in the context
of the episode from this week what where
did she say that did she throw dream a
birthday party she threw dream of her
birthday party yeah so there was like a
conversation one she's on the phone with
Rob planning the party like writing down
everything dream wants then at the party
like her and Scott are was Rob on camera
Rob no just his voice but she said she
thinks Rob will come back to the show
eventually that he talks about it and he
seemed extremely well on the phone like
they were just like having like a normal
brother sister combo
um
you would never know that like he he was
struggling for so long like it was just
totally a fine conversation about like
the kids party okay good I saw a bunch
of Clips Chloe said he's the best dad oh
which is really sweet yeah there were a
lot of Clips the episode like was I
actually didn't really love it um this
is all about this like Christmas album
which was
um
I think other people enjoyed it I I
don't know why I didn't it was like
really bothering me like they were the
clips that I saw were so funny no they
were recording this album it's like no
one wanted to record it and it's like
nobody has a gun to your guys's head
like you don't have to do things you
don't want to do this family and
Christmas like between the Christmas
card like they always there's so much I
guess that's kind of relatable like
holidays really bring out the worst in
people like when you're with your family
for so long but like they need to stop
doing things together on Christmas
because it's always a fight no and like
they're all freaking out about having to
sing like nobody wants to sing first of
all apparently Kendall has a good voice
she won't participate I saw that clip
are you kidding me that's so lame you
have a good voice let's hear it Kylie
wouldn't do it either because that's not
how she sees her singing career go and
she she was in one scene and she stole
the show
with her singing no with her commentary
she was like so funny
Kendall and Kylie are giving us nothing
Chloe literally was having a panic
attack about singing but she wouldn't
she wanted to do it because she had fomo
if they did it without her but she's
literally having a miserable time Kim
like doesn't you know how shy she
doesn't want to sing and she like runs
away and he's like calls baby face and
it's like let's do our own song and then
I can just like present it to the family
and I'll be like totally auto-tuned it's
like so literally not one of you wants
to do this why are we doing this and why
are they doing it whose idea is it it's
Courtney's idea she thinks it's a fun
way for the family to spend time
together they love Christmas Chris
Christmas song last year like charted
and they're gonna donate all the money
to charity but like why do I need to
listen to a Christmas song from a bunch
of people who don't want to be singing
who have really bad voices okay I agree
with that but I do like agree with
Courtney that it's a fun thing to do
it's for charity they love Christmas
like I don't know why everyone wouldn't
like want to be on board they're just
like the way that they're freaking out
about having to sing it's like are is
that normal
like nobody's putting your gun to your
head no and it's like I have the worst
voice but put me in the studio put
me in coach like they were so shy and
like literally freaking out like I can't
explain it and I was just like so why
are we doing this right
I don't know it was so honestly
unnecessary and bizarre and then we had
dreams birthday and then also um oh Kim
pranked the family saying she was gonna
be the bachelorette
oh I saw that clip going viral and
everyone was like is this real like how
dumb are you like how long do you have
to be like on the internet to like to
have awareness as to what's real and
what's not like never for one mere
moment did I think Kim Kardashian was
gonna be about Tourette when I saw that
clip they're like tune in to find out
and she was like pranking Chris and so
Chris like immediately calls Robert
Mills and is like right I heard you're
talking to Kim about being The
Bachelorette this is just like not how I
see her career going and it's like Kim's
career is gone like it is wherever it's
what it's where you can do whatever she
wants she has a four billion dollar
valuation for her company she's the most
famous woman in the world she can do
whatever the she wants you don't
have to worry about like her direction
of her career
it's like saying I don't know Bob Iger
doesn't know if he wants if his career
is where he wants it to be going the
thing with the pranks and the
Kardashians is like there are like a few
that are Beyond iconic of course like
Todd Crane's Art Van delay but for every
Art Van delay there's one of these like
there's so there's actually like 10 bad
pranks it's so true also for every one
good one the beginning of the episode
Chris and Scott were talking about
Mason's Bar Mitzvah and I saw that clip
too wow I've literally seen the whole
episode from Tick Tock you have that I'm
really excited for it was so cute so far
he's like steady I know with his tutor
he loves the tutor I'm obsessed I was
obsessed with that too I also think it
was like clearly um an intentional
conversation like wanting and I I
respect it like there was a lot of
conversation at that time in the culture
about Kanye and his stance on Jews and I
think this was a nice reminder like a
lot of the Kardashian kids are actually
Jewish right it was a really good time
for there to be a bar mitzvah Bar
Mitzvah no I said that's why they did it
but like you know can't we acknowledge
also uh I saw a lot of Clips I guess
there was a lot of like Scott and Chloe
you know time this episode and really
the more I watch like the more certain I
am that these two like that's how their
story ends like them them it ends with
them there's really no reason that it
doesn't end with them the whole show I
get it I get it it's weird no the e-show
plus this show like is just a whole long
storyline of a love story a love story
between Scott and Chloe yeah okay so
Mason's dad would also be his uncle like
it's fine
crazier things have happened especially
in that family I know I don't even think
it's like that disgusting
I don't think so either like Courtney
hates him hate with every fiber of her
being she didn't post for him on
Father's Day
I thought that was so weird did she pose
for Travis I believe so I remember I
remember watching her stories and be
like being like is she gonna like say
something about Scott because he is the
father of her children and I didn't see
anything if she posted something later
correct me but I did not see anything
damn I feel like there's such bad blood
they're never sure they're never in one
scene together
so maybe like a good way to warm up Tim
would be you know to see her sister so
happy
[Laughter]
yeah it's a theory oh and then there was
like a lit dinner between Scott Chloe
and Kim Kim was third week I saw that
one where they were just like talking to
the camera yeah talking about well I
really do not need to watch this episode
I've seen everything and they were
talking about like all the crazy things
people like say about them but it was
like things I've never heard like that
Kim had a tear and one of her
confessionals they said it was a CGI
tear oh I saw that it did look CGI I
guess but like that's okay that's not
what people are talking about like we're
talking about Balenciaga right and
you're not I don't know if Balenciaga
has happened yet in the show I don't
think it has because she's wearing it
literally walks into the piano lesson
with the song teacher and puts her
Balenciaga bag right off the piano
yeah no it's definitely before yeah
and we'll see if they discuss I am not
getting the vibe that they're going to
me neither because I think there's only
10 episodes in a season and like we're
halfway through oh yeah and
I feel like they would tease it more
they would tease it if they were talking
about it because they knew that we want
to hear about it yeah
darn darn darn
well I guess I'm not gonna be watching
the new episode of the Kardashians
because I've pretty much seen it
so there's that yeah
yeah that's our show I hope everyone has
an amazing weekend we are back on Monday
so don't miss your girlies too much but
make sure to rate review subscribe you
know so this episode can go number one
and beat smartless those guys thank
you so much for listening to the
testimony Morning Show where we love the
past five stories in each and every
Monday through Friday and YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe the thumbs up
also available Spotify
love you bye